on est dans une tension incroyable
c'est une expérience qui est assez folle
quoi un antistress
mais bon fallait
mettre au moins deux fugitifs
la priorité c'est quitter les caméras de
paris
on nous signale une célébrité en fuite
à partir de maintenant la traque
commence
le plan c nous rendre quasi invisible
au casting de rats musique
acteur provient de faire une erreur
jouets darcis dazhou est un chanteur
très connu d'art simon auteur de manga
si j'arrive à me repérer jusqu'ici en
français que
permis quelque chose dans mon sens laure
et florent manaudou deux médailles
olympiques en cavale ont tous bien
parano surtout j'espère qu'on va se
faire tuer
à tout moment quoi vous y est simple
après de youtube heures on est prêt les
autres
ne trouveront pas ici en tout cas c'est
peut-être qu'ils sont peut-être qu'ils
sont pas loin on va pas se faire
attraper regardez autour si vous les
voyez pas
on va vous retrouver la carte bleue a
été utilisé à 10h46
[Musique]
pas les louper la roue les stopper
on va vous retrouver